each night tens of thousands of people
sleep in tent cities crowding the
palm-lined boulevards of Los Angeles but
a struggling musician from South LA
thought he had a creative temporary fix
he crowdfunded $100,000 and built dozens
of solar-powered tiny houses to shelter
the homeless but on the morning city
officials were gathering to celebrate
their new nearly two billion dollar plan
to end homelessness police and garbage
crews were descending on the tiny homes
ordered by the city to seize and destroy
them Los Angeles emergency in the
country's second-largest such a problem
that's spinning out of control crisis
proportions there the shelter crisis as
the city is overwhelmed by spiking the
homeless population most camps are seen
everywhere has been living on the
sidewalk here for the past 30 years it
is behind this homeless crisis in LA
here in the entertainment capital of the
world
over half the homeless population will
sleep on the streets tonight far more
than in any other American city there
are 28,000 homeless people in just the
city of Los Angeles and the number has
hit new record highs in each of the past
few years but LA mayor Eric Garcetti has
a plan this is a bold step forward today
for Los Angeles
a year ago I'll be blunt the City
Council the mayor weren't working
together on this
Garcetti introduced a funding proposal
in February that would devote nearly two
billion dollars over the next decade to
getting all la residents off the streets
once and for all but at the time of
Garcetti s announcement dozens of
homeless people had already found
shelter in the form of solar-powered
tiny houses dispersed throughout the
neighborhoods of South LA and beyond in
Los Angeles a growing movement
a big impact it's an innovative effort
to help the homeless giving homes to the
homeless they were built by a
self-described struggling musician named
Elvis summers I got involved with
building tiny houses because of a woman
named smokey she's 62 years old this is
my neighborhood and as I got to know her
realize that she was sleeping in the
dirt and I decided to build a tiny house
in his 20s Summers was homeless for
stretches of time himself now the 39
year old is trying to help his neighbors
who have fallen on hard times some other
homeless people came by and asked if I
could build them one I didn't have the
money so I figured you try one of these
crowdfunding things I've seen out there
I mean blew my mind I mean I think I
passed 50 thousand in the first week
total I've raised you know over a
hundred thousand Summers has built tiny
homes for nearly 40 people
aided by professional contractors and
other volunteers who sign up to help
through his nonprofit starting human
each house costs roughly $1,200 for
materials the houses I build have carpet
two windows a steel reinforced door
smoke detector it's got a solar panel on
the roof powers two light bulbs and the
battery pack has a USB port on it to
charge your cell phone which is huge and
address American flag summers also
equips each of the six by ten foot
houses with a camping toilet and even
window alarms he says they were never
meant to be a permanent solution but
unlike sleeping on the sidewalk or in a
ten his tiny houses provide the secure
foundation residents need to improve
their lives
you know the tiny houses provide
immediate shelter you know the houses I
build a very sturdy and safe people can
lock their stuff up and know that when
they come back from their drug treatment
program or a court or finding a job all
day that this stuff is where they left
it I got my resume
my showers no were to not be homeless
want to order pizza Tomorrowland home
but as Summers was building houses anger
in the community over growing street
homelessness was reaching a boiling
point early this year these homes was
nothing more than a detriment to mine in
my neighbors homes families in children
and they created a sense of terror in
the residents nestled within dour tent
shanty towns summerses tiny houses
became brightly colored targets for
residents who want the homeless out of
their backyards they had the children
walking in the middle of the street and
not on the curbside when they're going
over the overpasses
most of summerses tiny houses were
placed on private land that's been
donated to the project such as a parking
lot outside a convenience store in a
church in Compton a handful replaced the
tents that have proliferated on freeway
overpasses they're not right in front of
a business they're not in you know in
front of somebody's house and the
sidewalks are extra wide so you know it
seemed as far as public places the
safest best place to be until I could
get land and then take them and put them
on on property building a small
community but la viewed the houses as a
nuisance in February the City Council
amended a sweeps ordinance to allow the
tiny houses to be seized without prior
notice
on the morning of the ninth police and
garbage trucks descended telling three
of the houses to a bureau sanitation lot
for disposal my phone just blows up by
everybody on 42nd Street just freaking
out like they're throwing us out of the
houses they're telling us they're taking
them like what do we do I mean they
wouldn't let them get their clothes or
their medications they threw them out
left them on the sidewalk I pleaded with
them I was like okay we'll look they
have wheel locks on them let me unlock
the wheels at least you know so you
don't break them No they refused they
just wanted to take them and destroy
summers managed to move eight of the
threatened houses into storage before
they were confiscated but their
residents had nowhere to go
I had to evict to veterans who paid
their ticket they shouldn't be homeless
period you know I get angry they did
their service they gave up their dreams
so the rest of us can be out here and be
a bunch of [ __ ] you know there needs
to be some respect our community was so
negatively impacted by these structures
that many of us come together to get
them removed we call councilman prices
office because we needed him to do
something about it
I don't think living in that box is the
alternative to having some housing
current price is the LA City Councilman
who represents the district where the
houses were located and who ordered the
seizures might have been objections to
the timely houses everyone call them
houses it really just box they're
multicolored boxes is that they're safe
they're not safe and that they impose
real hazards for other neighbors in the
community people in neighborhoods that
are concerned about all of that their
property values and you know tiny houses
and homeless people in their
neighborhood have every right period to
be pissed off and I completely agree
with them but you know you're
misdirecting your anger direct it to the
powers that be that are supposed to be
doing their job
my whole issue and cause is that
something needs to be done right now
until permanent housing does come
available I think just just a temporary
fix is a false sense of security as
would the
timbi without any real supportive
services but two homeless people who had
escaped tents and moved into the tiny
homes the security they provided seemed
anything but false after the city's
sweep they were forced once again to
call the sidewalk home I've been home is
like two years one of the guys Willie
who's an engineer who I gave the red
house to he used to have it right here
in the house you feel secure could you
we plugged your lucky door
after Willie had Knotts house was seized
by the city he went back to living in a
tent above the 110 freeway
I tried to cover it up you know as much
as I can but hey at the as he taken cut
it with a razor blades much much kid you
have it all you know it's coming you
know that they really don't care for you
too much they said first thing officer
told me he said well go get a job my
second you help me good one I'm willing
to work it's not really all in little
jobs map it Eli Harold
go Willie is an ex engineer he loves
kids
he loves tinkering with things and I
have a little a little platform like a
little stands for that I build to put
this on it that's a little wood toy a
man but you know some kid with a lot of
hats man and I got this out of duster
which I really don't like say but I do
go dumpster diving
okay a few days after I gave him his
house he pulled me aside and basically
did I mean he just told me that like he
was so low and there's just no hope and
he basically was just used given up and
he was contemplating ending his life
finally getting hope there's a chance
you know maybe I can turn this around
and then just you know having someone
come and suck it away from you it's
horrible I put a lot into it you don't
saying I'm not saying I wanted a lot
back but I I was securing what I had my
little house man my little houses made
the world for me and it still means the
world to me
we've offered housing to individuals who
are willing to come in and you know
frequently the responses well I don't
want to go to the shelter I just want to
stay here on the street there are a
fraction of shelter space to how many
people are homeless but otherwise the
shelters are dirty it's dangerous in
there the food is not good it's got
bedbugs you can't go with a girlfriend
pets or any of your personal items that
let's suggesting that the shelters are
the answer that obviously is a temporary
step of an alternative step I think it's
a better step you know than someone
sleeping on the sidewalk under a bench
or on a [ __ ] I think the way you make
it better is having some kind of
coordinated services you know where you
can refer people to the kind of
assistance they need as opposed to
giving them a structure letting them
think that they've got it there okay now
because they had a little they're
sitting in a little box and it their
problems are gonna be solved you you go
out and spend you know many nights on
the street and be treated as a monster
and then be given you know a warm place
to stay and tell me you're not going to
call it a home when the city took those
three houses they chose to do it at the
exact same time
that the council in the mayor were at
City Hall unveiling the mayor's new
homeless 1.8 7 billion dollar plan this
is an important policy statement and I
think it's going to provide it with a
road map in a variety of areas we are
beginning to make a difference and a
difference that is long overdue we've
identified some some action items
working closely with the county and so
we're working really in collaboration
ways that we happen before we have
identified and need to come some funds a
specific number some funding for
prolonged period of time everything that
they have been doing and you know
doesn't work it's just years of circles
and you know bureaucratic holds and wait
times and you know like I would like
them to care 10 20 30 40 years I mean
water salt house mayor Garcetti z' plan
focuses on permanent supportive housing
aiming to build 10,000 units for
homeless families over the next decade
but in the meantime la is taking funds
away from temporary shelters the tiny
houses are you know a cheap effective
immediate step and as long as they are
you know managed in small communities
that would be best I've almost completed
my first mobile shower unit which super
excited to get done
currently Los Angeles owns thousands of
vacant lots that could provide locations
for micro housing villages like those
that already exist in several other
cities including Portland Seattle Austin
and elsewhere I mean not only they could
open a few up that have been sitting
there for decades that we could build
communities on but open up a warehouse
and stop chastising the homeless for
collecting the good citizens garbage
encourage them give them a job doing it
well we're trying we're trying to come
up some solutions you know we're looking
at letting people stay in the parking
lots for example you know the publicity
the veteran vehicles the parking parking
labs perhaps that could be a good
location for tents for for other types
of temporary shelters in May following
national media attention Los Angeles
returned the tiny houses it had seized
with their solar power systems missing
on the condition that summers placed
them only
property as for mayor Garcetti in the
City Council they scored a success on
the November ballot as LA voters
approved a 1.2 billion dollar bond
measure to partially fund new permanent
housing construction exactly a decade
after the city's first ten-year plan to
end homelessness withered in 2006 every
Angelino deserves a safe place to sleep
at night the mayor's office says that
though the city appreciates citizens
creative solutions to end homelessness
he does not support opening a surplus
slot for Elvis summers or other tiny
house village concepts until the city
has some more time to study the issue
business as usual for me I'm going to
keep building I'm going to keep helping
these people this can all change I mean
if people want a beautiful positive
community you have to build one you
can't just you know sweep stuff under
the rug and pretend it doesn't exist if
I you know can't get through to the city
to open their minds to actually give a
crap about what's going on you know to
the people of our city and create change
with me you know I'll do it myself then
and with all the support that I do get
and everybody that doesn't want to come
and contribute
I'll get private land we'll build small
communities we'll save these people's
lives
[Music]
I've got a walking along
I have a friend right here I do have
that
[Music]